[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
الخلافات بين زعيم قوه فاغنر ووزير الدفاع
الروسي تظهر للعالم يتعهد بمراحقه الخونه
هزات ارتداديه جديده تضرب مدينه القاهره
وفلسطين ولبنان
نتنياهو يتحدث عن رفع مستوى الجهوزي لشن
هجوم ضد منشات نوويه ايرانيه بعد خمسه
اجتماعات سريه
شرطه الاخلاق الايرانيه تعود الى الواجهه
مجددا والحرس الثوري يطالب باخفاء
ميزانيتها
مجال النقل الجوي
خطاب الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حمل
رسائل كثيره لعل ابرزها اشاره الى وجود
انقسام داخلي بوتين توعد بمطارده ومحاكمه
من سماهم بالخونه كل الذين اختاروا خيانه
روسيا يجب ان يحاسبوا امام القانون
في الان ذاته مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر وجه
اسلحته الكلاميه اتجاه وزير الدفاع الروسي
سيرجي شويغو ورئيس الاركان متهما اياهما
بمحاوله تدمير قواته وحرمان مقاتلي
المجموعه من الذخائر فالخطوه ترقى الى
الخيانه العظمى يقول زعيم فاجنر مجاني
[موسيقى]
حكايه الانقسامات في روسيا ليست وليده
اليوم وزير الدفاع سيرجي شويغو اختفى في
اكثر الايام المستعره بعد بدايه الحرب
العام الماضي ولمده اسبوعين تقريبا قبل ان
يظهر من جديد حينها قيل ان اختلاف موقفه
مع رؤيه بوتين ابعده عن الساحه
القصه لا تنتهي هنا الرئيس الشيشاني
الموالي لموسكو رمضان قديروف سبق وفتح
النار ايضا على قاده الحرب الروس سبتمبر
الماضي بعد الحمله العسكريه المضاده من
الجانب الاوكراني وقتها طالب بتغيير
استراتيجيه الحرب احداث تطفو على السطح
رغم ان بوتين يلوح دائما بورقه التوحد
خلفه لكنه لم يستطع ان يخفي جبل
الانقسامات بلال البجدين العربيه
حذر مجلس الامن الروسي من يسار واشنطن على
هزيمه روسيا مؤكدا ان ذلك يفتح الباب امام
صراع نووي وقال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي دمت في بيان ان روسيا سوف تدافع عن
نفسها بكل سلاح بما في ذلك بالسلاح النووي
اذا اثرت واشنطن على هزيمتها واشار الى ان
ادراج الترسانه النوويه البريطانيا او
فرنسا في معاهده كان يجب ان يحدث منذ فتره
طويله اكدت الخارجيه الروسيه قدره موسكو
على مراقبه امتثال الولايات المتحده
لاحكام ستارت بعد قرار موسكو تعليق العمل
بالمعاهده وقالت في بيان ان روسيا باتت
تمتلك كل الامكانات اللازمه لردع النووي
ولا يمكنها الان التراضي عن امكانات فرنسا
وبريطانيا العسكريه ونوويه واتحادهما
واشنطن في وجه موسكو
اتهم رئيس مجلس الدومه الروسي
الولايات المتحده بتدمير بنيه الاستخاره
الدولي بتوقفه عن الوفاء بالتزاماتها
ورفضها لمقترحات روسيا بشان قضايا الامن
العالمي ومن المقرر ان يبحث الدوما اليوم
مشروع قانون مقدم من الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين لتعليق مشاركه موسكو في معاهده
مشروع القانون
في المقابل المشاهدين اشاد الرئيس
الاوكراني
على خط المواجهه فيما تتحدث روسيا عن
احراز تقدم نحو هدفها الرئيسي في المنطقه
وقالت في خطابه الليلي انه لم يطرا اي
تغيير على الخطوط الاماميه رغم الضغوط
الكبيره التي تمارسها القوات الروسيه على
قوته برجع
اكثر التقارير اللافته هي تلك الوارده من
دون ايلونسك قواتنا تتشبث بمواقعها على خط
المواجهه في شرق اوكرانيا ضد الهجمات
الروسيه المستمره والتي لم تتوقف على
الرغم من تكبدها خسائر فادحه من المهم جدا
ان نذكر انه لم يطرا اي تغيير على الخطوط
الاماميه على الرغم من الضغوط الكبيره
التي تواجهها القوات الاوكرانيه واشكر
جميع مقاتلين الصامدين في الجبهات
الاماميه
وما هي تداعيات هذه الاتهامات وتجاذبات
بين قائد مجموعه فاغنر والقياده العسكريه
الروسيه
مرحبا بك احمد بالفعل يعني هي ليست المره
الاولى التي يخرج فيها
رئيس القوات الخاصه
بالتصريحات يعني توجه الاصابع الاتهام الى
المسؤولين او الوزاره الدفاع بالتحديد عن
وجود تقصير ما كما تناولت مرارا وسائل
اعلام الروسيه ولكن حقيقه الدفاع الروسيه
يوم امس نفت وجود اي تقصير من الجانب
جانب وزاره الدفاع من حيث ارسال الزخائر
الى القوات المتطوعه كما تسميها موسكو قد
تحدثت يوم امس ان انه تم ارسال بين فتره
18 وعشرين فبراير نحو 10,000 قذيفه
صاروخيه بالاضافه الى نحو
1500 قذيفه مدفعيه بالاضافه لذلك هي قام
او اشادت
تقدم الذي تقوم به القوات المتطوعه في
بالاخص عند منطقه ضخمه قالت انها تقدمت
حتى الان نحو اثنين ونصف كيلو متر على
الارض هي اشادت بعملهم على الارض بالاضافه
الى عمل القوات الروسيه هناك وهذا دليل
على انها تحاول
الالتفاف او التغطيه على هذا وجود في حال
وجود خلاف ما طبعا التغطيه عليها هذه ليست
المره الاولى ايضا التي تقوم الدفاع
الروسيه بخروج ببيان ينفي وجود اي خلاف
بين القوات المتطوعه
والقوات الروسيه التي تعمل على الارض احمد
هل هناك معلومات حول طبيعه او اساس هذا
الصراع بين الطرفين ما مرده تحديدا يعني
هل هناك صراع نفوذ بين الطرفين هل هو عدم
رضا من عسكريين في وزاره الدفاع بمشاركه
في هذه الحرب ما الذي يقوله المراقبون
العسكريون حول ذلك
حقيقه احمد المعلومات هي شحيحه طبعا حول
هذا الصدد لان
الخلاف يظهر فقط من جانب واحد او من
تصريحات جانب واحد التي التي هي اقوات
فاغنر الخاصه او بالتحديد في طبعا التي
اعتبرته الدفاع يوم امس في بيانها وانه قد
يؤدي هذا التفكك او عدم التعاون والانسجام
بين قوات المتطوع المتطوعه والقوات
الرسميه او القوات الجيش الروسي سيؤدي الى
تراجع في التقدم كما تحدثت الدفاع الروسيه
اذا الخلاف يظهر دائما من جانب واحد وهو
جانب القوات الخاصه
لن يكن هناك نهائيا اي تصريح رسمي سواء من
الكرملين او سواء من الدفاع الروسيه تظهر
وجود خلافات بين الهيئات سواء كانت
الرسميه او الهيئات الشركات الخاصه التي
ايضا تحارب مع الى جانب القوات الروسيه
كما تعلم ان هناك ليست فقط القوات الروسيه
القوات وقوات الانفصاليه التي ايضا تقود
هذه المعركه ولم يكن هناك نهائيا وجود
لتصريحات رسميه تؤكد وجود خلافات تصريحات
هي فقط من جانب قوات التي طبعا اعتبرت ان
هناك تقصيرا من ناحيه تزويد قواته
بالذخائر او حتى من انتقادات سابقه كان قد
وجهها هو ودعمها ايضا الرئيس الشيشاني الى
قدره القاده هناك بعد طبعا الانسحاب من
عده مناطق اخرها كان طبعا خرسون
شكرا لك على كل هذه الاضاحات وتفاصيل
مشاهدينا نقل الصحيفه عن مصادر مطلعه ان
الرئيس الصيني شوجن يستعد لزياره موسكو
لعقد قمه مع نظيره الروسيه
واضاف التقرير ان اجتماع شيما بوتين سيكون
في اطار مسعى لعقد محادثات سلام متعدده
الاطراف وسيسمح للصين بتكرار دعوتها لعدم
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه هذا ويجري الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن اليوم محادثات في
وارسوم مع اعضاء مجموعه بوخارست تسعه
والتي تضم دول الجناح الشرقي لحلف الناتو
ومن المقرر ان يجدد الرئيس بايد من خلال
لقاءاته تاكيده على دعم اوكرانيا في
مواجهه روسيا وعلى دعم بلاده الثابت
الجناح الشرقي في حلف شمال اطلسي مجموعه
بوخارستسعه مشاهدينا تضم اعضاء في حلف
الناتو من شرق ووسط اوروبا وهي بلغاريا
وهنغاريا واستونيا وليتوانيا
وجمهوريه التشيك
الاتهامات المتبادله بين واشنطن وموسكو
اكد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن خلال وجوده
في بولندا ان الولايات المتحده والدول
الاوروبيه لا تسعى لمهاجمه روسيا مضيفا ان
الحرب في اوكرانيا غير ضروريه واختارها
الرئيس بوتين نتابع
اتحدث مره اخرى مع الشعب الروسي الولايات
المتحده والدول الاوروبيه لا تسعى لمهاجمه
روسيا وبالنسبه لملايين المواطنين الروس
الذين يرغبون العيش بسلام فان هذه الحرب
غير ضروريه بل هي تراجيديه اختارها الرئيس
بوتين فهي حرب من صنعه المساله بسيطه على
بوتين ان يتوقف عن غزو اوكرانيا وبذلك
نصدر ستار الحرب
شدد رئيس الاوكرانيه
ميلاده على خط المواجهه فيما تتحدث روسيا
عن احراز تقدم نحو هدفها الرئيسي في
المنطقه وقال في خطابه الليلي المصور انه
لم يطرا اي تغيير على الخطوط الاماميه رغم
الضغط الكبير من جانب القوات الروسيه
هي تلك الوارده من دونيسك قواتنا تتشبث
بمواقعها على خط المواجهه في شرق اوكرانيا
ضد الهجمات الروسيه المستمره والتي لم
تتوقف على الرغم من تكبدها خسائر فادحه من
المهم جدا ان نذكر انه لم يطرا اي تغيير
على الخطوط الاماميه على الرغم من الضغوط
الكبيره التي تواجهها القوات الاوكرانيه
واشكر جميع مقاتلين الصامدين في الجبهات
الاماميه
اهلا بك احمد ودعنا نبدا من التي وصلت
اليها يوم امس وتدور حولها معارك شرسه
لسعادتها من قبل ارز ما هي ابرز مشاهداتك
في المدينه احمد
نعم احمد اهلا بك يعني انا الان اقف في
ساحه الحريه في وسط هذه الساحه هي الساحه
الاكبر ليس فقط في اوكرانيا وانما في جميع
دول اوروبا قاطبه هذه الساحه كما ترى من
خلفي هي ساحه شبه فارغه من المواطنين
والسيارات قبل عام كانت هذه الساحه ملئه
بالمواطنين والسيارات وغيرها في هذه
الساحه يوجد من خلفي اثنين من اكبر
الجامعات في اوكرانيا في الجهه الاخرى
هناك
المبنى الاداره الاقليميه في خاركيف وكما
تشاهد اثر عام من الحرب واضح على هذه
المدينه الحدوديه مع روسيا قبل قليل دوات
صافرات الانذار التي دوت بالامس ايضا يبدو
ان الصفرات الانذار يعني يعني تكون مستمره
في خاركيف وفي كثير من المناطق الحدوديه
مع روسيا كان هناك قصف لمنطقه كوبي نيسك
هذا القصف اسفر عن اصابه
المواطنين لكن الاشتراكات الاعنف بطبع
تدور في مناطق
ولوجانسك هذه المناطق التي تشهد
الاشتباكات
الاقوى كان هناك قصف مدفعي من قبل القوات
الروسيه القوات الروسيه وفقت وفقا لهيئه
الدفاع الاوكرانيه تحاول السيطره على بعض
طرق الامداد للجيش الاوكراني لقاتل عمداد
خاصه في منطقه مخموت التي تقع في مقاطعه
دنيتك لكن هناك العديد من طرق الامداد
الموجوده لدى الجيش الاوكراني اذا قطع
طليفه هناك العديد من الطرق كما ذكر
الرئيس الاوكراني لم يكن هناك تقدم يذكر
للجيش الروسي هناك محاولات للتقدم لكن لم
يحدث هذا التقدم على اطلاق هناك ثبات في
الموقف الجنود الاوكران على الجبهات
المختلفه تحدثت بالامس مع عمده خاركيف
الذي اكد
ان هناك في خركيف اكثر من 150 الف مواطن
بلا ماوى لا يوجد سقف يغطي رؤوسهم ولا
يعني هم في حاجه الى الكثير من الخدمات
التي يجب ان تقدم لهم في حاجه الى بيوت
وغيرها تحدث ايضا عن دعم الذي وعدت به
اوكرانيا هو يقول ان خركيف من اكثر
المناطق المتضرره يجب ان يقدم اليها الدعم
بصوره سريعه لترميم الاماكن التي دمرت
دعني اتحرك بالكاميرا اذا كان لديك واحد
الوقت يعني كما ترى من خلفه هذه يعني
بالخلف هناك اثنين من اكبر الجامعات وفي
الجهه المقابله يوجد مبنى الاداره
الاقليميه هذا المبنى ايضا الذي بات خاليا
تماما بعد ان تم قصفه قبل اشهر من قبل
الطيران الروسي النوافذ جميعها تم تدميرها
جراء هذا القصف تم سد هذه النوافز بصوره
واضحه كما ترى يمكن للمصور ان يبرز هذا
الامر يعني كيف تعاني بصوره كبيره هذه
المعاناه يقول مواطنين انهم قادرون على
احتمالها لكن يجب احمد يعني بعد غد ستكون
الذكرى السنويه الاولى لهذه الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه بكل ما حملته من الام وماسي
باختصار احمد كيف يستعد سكان
لاحياء ذكرى هذه الحرب
يعني سكان خاركيف يقولون ان هم يتوقعون ان
يكون هناك شيء قوي من قبل الجانب الروسي
والقوات الروسيه خاصه مع ما يتم اذاعته في
وسائل الاعلام من ان روسيا تريد تحقيق
انتصار ولو معنوي تتحدث به في الذكرى
الاولى الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا هم
يعني يقولون انه لابد لدعم الغربي ان يكون
ذو تاثير كبير يعني كان هناك حديث عن اكثر
من 67 مليار دولار ما وصل اقل من نصف هذا
المبلغ لذلك يجب لهذه الوعود ان تكون
حقيقيه المدارس تم يعني تم توجيه جميع
المدارس في ليس في كيف فقط وانما في جميع
الاماكن عن التعليم عن بعد خلال الايام
القادمه بالمناسبه التعليم هنا في خاركيف
يعني الجامعات مغلقه بصوره تامه المدارس
مغلقه التعليم كله عن بعد هذه احد الاثار
الموجوده لان تدوي سفرات الانذار بصوره
مستمره ولا يعرف ان كانت قصف قد يصيب هذه
الاماكن وهذا الامر يتم التعامل مع بصوره
حاسمه من قبل الاداره هنا اذا دوت صفرات
الانذار يجب على المحل ان تغلق المطاعم
تغلق كما تشاهد نحن في مكان نتحدث عن اكبر
ميدان ليس في اوكرانيا وانما في اوروبا
خاطبه هذا الميدان كما تشاهد من خلفه يعني
شبه خالي من المواطنين والسيارات وهذا
يوضح كيف هي الامور بعد عام كامل الحرب في
خاركيف شكرا لك على كل ما تفضلت به من
المعلومات وتفاصيل من خارج كنت معنا
مشاهدينا مع اقتراب مرور عامنا على الحرب
الاوكرانيه كشف دراسه اعدها معهد اي دبليو
عنتاب التي ادت الى اضطرابات في الامدادات
والانتاج على مستوى العالم وارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه بشكل كبير وانخفاض القضاه الشرائيه
وارتفاع معدل التضخم
اكبر ازمه اقتصاديه يمر بها العالم سببها
الحرب في اوكرانيا
عقوبات قاسيه فرضت على روسيا قابلتها
سلسله من حزم الدعم المالي لاوكرانيا
وفق دراسه اجراها معهد اي دبليو الالماني
الحرب في اوكرانيا كلفت الاقتصاد العالمي
اكثر من تريليون و600 مليار دولار لكن
التكلفه الاقتصاديه كانت هائله بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا التي تقلص ناتجها المحلي
الاجمالي بنسبه
35% في عام 2022 وفقا للبنك الدولي قدرت
اكاديميه كييف للاقتصاد الاضرار بنحو 188
مليار دولار
يتوقع معهد اي دبليو الالماني ان تصل
خسائر الانتاج العالمي الى حوالي تريليون
دولار اخرى هذا العام
ذكريات الماضي وانعكاساتها على الحرب
الاوكرانيه دائما ما كانت حديث الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين هذه المره سلطه
الفرنسيه الضوء على طفوله وشباب الرئيس
الاوكراني مع الهيمنه السوفيتيه على بلدته
في اوكرانيا نتابع
رئيس الاوكراني من الاتحاد السوفيتي ومن
ثم روسيا لم يكن يوما وليدا لحظه عداء بل
تراكم منذ الصغر زينسكي الرئيس لم يختلف
يوما عن الطفل مواقف عده رصدتها
عكست تاثير نشاه زلنسكي على توجهاته
وصراعه الدائري مع روسيا مرحله الطفوله
كان عمر الطالب زيلنسكي عشره اعوام عام
1988 اثناء الاحتفال بثوره اكتوبر او
الثوره البلشفيه امر المعلم بوقوف الطلاب
في ساحه الشعله الابديه في بلدته ووفقا
الفرنسيه لا ينسى توبيخه مع زملائه بسبب
عدم كي الوشاح الاحمر لمنظمه الشباب
الشيوعي مرحله الشباب في شبابه اعتاد
زلنسكي على الاحتفال امام النصب التذكاري
للجنود الذين حرروا مدينته عام
1944 وفي عام 2023 لم يتغير النصب
التذكاري وظل الذكرى تحرير بلدته من
النظام الشيوعي ترافق مشواره من الفن الى
السياسه رمزيه مسقط راس زينسكي مدينه
كريفيريخ كانت مركزا مهما للمجهود الحربي
ايام التحدي الجمهوريات السوفيتيه وظلت
كذلك الى اليوم فلم يعد زيلنسكي الى مسقط
راسه منذ بدء الحرب بسبب القصف المتواصل
عليها
لكل من الرئيسين الاوكراني والروسي مخزون
من ذكريات الماضي صور ضلت عالقه في
الاذهان وتظهر على السطح كل ما اشتدت حده
الصراع الروسي الاوكرانيه عن السمان
العربيه
نشاطنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل بعد
اربعين ساعه تحت الانقاض الطفل شام نجت من
حطام زلزال لتواجه خطرا اخر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد بتروس الساقين
خطر يواجه طفله السوريه شاموا اخرين كثر
نجوا من زلزال لكنهم لم ينجوا من الاصابه
بمتالي بمتلازمه العرس حيث تخضع الطفله
الشام التي ضلت اربعين ساعه تحت الانقاض
بعد انهيار منزلها وسقوط السقف على ساقيها
للمراقبه منذ ايام في العنايه المركزه في
مستشفى في مدينه ادلب الاطباء اكد ان طفله
تواجه خطر بتري رجليها على مستوى الساقين
كما انها معرضه لمشكلات في القلب والكلى
وهي حاله من حالات عده في مستشفيات
المنطقه وفق الاطباء فان متلازمه الحرس
تنتج عن اي ضغط تتعرض له الاطراف لفتره
طويله تفوق اثنتي عشره ساعه ما يؤدي الى
انقطاع الدوره الدمويه على مستوى الانسجه
مؤكدين ان المصابه لا يواجه خطر التعرض
للبتر فحسب بل يتعرضوا مشاكل اخرى في
القلب والقصور الكلوي كمان
[موسيقى]
الخيال جديده
لياخذ عن قدره الى احضان زوج عمتها الذي
تبناها بعد موجه عالميه عرضت تبنيها
المزيد من التفاصيل متابعه
[موسيقى]
وانا عم احفر طلع صوت الطفله هي بلشت تصرخ
انا ما بالي انها الطفله او كذا بلشت اصيح
وكذا اقول لهم ابو ردينه عايش عايش بلشت
اشيل النوبه التراب طلعت هي الطفله
[موسيقى]
يلا يلا يلا
العربيه محمد الاشقر اهلا بك محمد وقد
علمت محمد انك كنت في تواصل مع اطباء
الطفل شام ما الذي يمكن ان تخبرنا به عن
تخبرنا به عن حالتها الصحيه
تسمعني محمد
طيب محمد لو كنت تسمعني كنت سالتك عن
الحاله الصحيه للطفله شام اذا كنت قد
تعرفت على بعض المعلومات او وصلت اليك بعض
المعلومات من الاطباء اذا يبدو اننا فقدنا
الاتصال مع الزميل محمد وسنعود اليك من
جديد اذا مشاهدينا في اخر التطورات
المتعلقه بزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا اعلنت اداره الكوارث التركيه عن
حدوث هزه ارتداديه جديده بقوه اربع درجات
فاصله واحد على مقياس ريختر في قهرمان
مرعش كما اكد المركز الامريكي للزلازل بان
مركز الهزه التي بلغت قوتها اربع درجات
فاصل اربعه كان في اعماق المتوسط لبنان من
جهه اخرى اعلنت اداره الكوارث في ايران عن
هزه ارضيه بقوه خمس درجات فاصله خمسه
بمقياس ريختر ظهرت مناطق بمحافظه فارس
جنوب غرب البلاد
هذا هو اعلن المرصد السوري ارتفاع حاصله
ضحايا زلزال السادس من فبراير في الشمال
السوري الى قرابه سته الاف وسبعمائه
وخمسين شخصا واكد المقصد ان المئات لا
يزالون بحاله حرجه المرصد اشار الى ان عدد
الضحايا السوريين جراء زلزال في جنوب
تركيا تم وتم ادخالهم ايضا من المعابر
التركيه الى سوريا بلغ نحو 1800 منذ
السادس من فبراير نتابع
هزه ارضيه فيها تايا التركيه اكملت تدمير
ما تضرر من مباني في الزلزال الاول قوتها
كانت 6.3 على سلم ريختر 6000 هزه ارضيه
واكثر خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين ضربت
جنوبيه تركيا وشماليه سوريا منذ اول
زلزالين في السادس من فبراير الحالي
كل الارتدادات التي ضربت تركيا وسوريا
والبلدان القريبه كانت عند الاربع درجات
على سلم ريختار الا ان زلزال امس فقد 6
درجات الامر الذي اثار تساؤلات حول ماهيته
هل هي هزه ارتداديه ام انه زلزال اخر
علميا حسب هيئه المسح الجيولوجي الامريكيه
تكون الهزات الارتداديه اقل قوه من
الزلزال الرئيسي وتتناقص تدريجيا الى ان
تنتهي هذا يدل ان المنطقه المنكوبه هي في
ذروه النشاط الزلزالي
الهيئه الامريكيه اكدت ان الزلزال الاول
في غاز عنتاب تسبب في كسر على الفالق
الزلزالي طوله يصل الى 350 كيلو مترا
ويتطلب هذا النوع من الكسور الى وقت طويل
لكي يلتئم وبالتالي يجب توقع حدوث هزات
اخرى
الاخبار الكاذبه والتنبؤات غير العلميه
التي انتشرت عبر وسائل التواصل اثارت ضجه
وزادت مخاوف الجمهور لكن هيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكيه نفت بشكل قاطع قدره
التنبؤ بالزلازل الكبيره
انس النماسي العربيه
اتجاه تصاعدي تتخذه الهزات الارتداديه
التي اعقبت زلزال سوريا وتركيا عددا وقوه
حيث وقعت اكثر من سته الاف واربعين هزه
ارتداديه وصلت قوه احداها لسته فاصل اربعه
درجه اي بمثابه زلزال اخر هذه الحقائق
اضيفت الى تحليلات تهويليه وتنبؤات بان
الهزات هي تمهيد لزلزال اكبر واقوى لكن ما
هي الهزات الارتداديه وهل فعلا هناك زلزال
اخر متوقع اكثر تدميرا وفق خبراء
جيولوجيين كلما كانت الهزه الاساسيه قويه
كلما تبعتها هزات ارتداديه اكثر على مدى
اطول يمتد احيانا لايام واسابيع وحتى اشهر
فعند وقوع زلزال قوي يتحرك قسم كبير من
الفالق الزلزالي المسبب ولكن ليس بالكامل
وبالتالي القسم الذي لم يتحرك سيواصل بعد
الزلزال لحين عوده الارض الى طبيعتها وهو
ما يسبب الهزات الارتداديه خبراء اكدوا ان
بعض الهزات لم تكن ارتداديه بل هزات
مستقله حدثت على فوالق اخرى نتيجه ضغط
تسبب به الزلزال الكبير على ما يحيط من
فوالق اما التحذير من امكانيه وقوع زلزال
اقوى فاحتماليته ضعيفه وفق علماء بحكم عدم
اتصال الفوالق لا سيما ان الزلزال القوي
الذي ضرب قبل اسبوعين حرر القسم الاكبر من
الطاقه الضاغطه فيما القسم الاخر ينتقل من
مكان الى اخر ويحدث الاهتزازات
مشاهدينا نقعد مره اخرى الى مراسلنا من
ادلب او من ريف ادلب محمد الاشقر اهلا بك
محمد وكنت قد سالتك قبل قليل عن ما توفى
لك المعلومات حول الحاله الصحيه للطفل شام
نعم يعني الطفله شام في احد مشافي مدينه
ادلب في تخضع للعنايه المركزه وتحديدا في
مشفى الشفاء ضمن المدينه طبعا الطفله
مهدده ببتر اها نتيجه سقوط سقف منزلها
عليها وبقائها تحت الانقاض مده طويله
تجاوزت الاربعين ساعه طبعا تعاني ايضا
الطفله شام من من بعض يعني الامراض في
والاعراض في القلب والكلى وجسدها يعني
الطفل الى حد هذه اللحظه في العنايه
المركزه يشرف عليها العديد من الاطباء ضمن
كوادر مشفى الشفاء كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل
ضمن المدينه طبعا
الشام هي من مدينه ارمناز غرب ادلب يعني
اصيبت نتيجه انهيار منزلها في الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب المنطقه هذا الانهيار ادى
لمقتل امها وشقيقه
وشقيقتها في حين نشت هي وابيها واثنين من
اشقائها طيب محمد هل هي غائبه عن الوعي هل
سيواصل الاطباء علاجها في ادلب ام ان هناك
فرص او محاولات لعلاجها في او نقلها الى
مكان اخر
نعم يعني في الحقيقه الطفل الان في
العنايه المركزه هي هي اغلب الاوقات تكون
غائبه عن الوعي وفي بعض الاحيان تستيقظ
طبعا جميع المحاولات الان هي لمعالجتها في
ادلب نظرا لان الحدود مغلقه لا توجد
امكانيه لنقلها الى خارج الحدود السوريه
مثلا نقلها لتركيا لان جميع المعابر مغلقه
امام الحالات الطبيه ولكن يسعى الجميع هنا
لانقاذ الطفله شام كما يحاول الجميع
لانقاذ المئات من الاطفال التي الذين في
حالاتهم تشابه حاله الطفله شام في في عموم
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا اذا من ريف ادلب كنت
معنا مراسل العربيه محمد الاشقر شكرا لك
محمد على هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
كشفت القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه ان
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
وقرر في ختام هذه المناقشات رفع مستوى
الاستعداد الاسرائيلي بشكل كبير على
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه واوضحت القناه
وغيرهم بانهم اذا لم يتمكنوا من التصرف مع
التطورات في ايران فان اسرائيل ستتصرف
لوحدها كما افادت القناه ايضا بان اسرائيل
ارسلت رسائل الى حركه حماس وحزب الله
مفادها ان الوضع السياسي المتفجر في
اسرائيل لا يمنع الجيش من شن عمل عسكري في
غزه او لبنان والرد بشكل قوي ضد اي محاوله
لمساسي بامن اسرائيل حسب تعبيره
هذا وشدد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي على
ضروره التكاتف الجهود لمنع ايران من
امتلاك الاسلحه النوويه في اشاره الى ان
اتخاذ هذا النوع من الخطوات سيضمن مصلحه
العالم اجمع وليس اسرائيل فقط
استطيع ان اقول لكم انني سافعل كل ما في
وسعي لمنع ايران من الحصول على اسلحه
نوويه انها ليست مصلحه اسرائيليه فقط بل
مصلحه امريكيه وهي مصلحه للعالم اجمع كلما
طال الانتظار زادت صعوبه تنفيذه لقد
انتظرنا مده اكثر من كافيه فرض الامريكيون
العقوبات وهكذا جاءت ايران الى طاوله
المفاوضات لكنهم تركوا المال على الطاوله
وتوصلوا الى صفقه سيئه الشيء الوحيد الذي
منع بعض الدول من تطوير اسلحه نوويه هو
تهديد عسكري موثوق به او عمل عسكري موثوق
يمكن ان يقترن ذلك بعقوبات اقتصاديه خانقه
لكنها ليست شرطا كافيا الشرط الضروري هو
عمل عسكري ذو مصداقيه
ومن قسم مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه زياد حلبي اهلا بك زياد وهل توفر
المزيد من المعلومات حول هذه الاجتماعات
السريه بين نتنياهو
دراماتيكيه لبقيت سريه في المقام الاول
بدون ان نشات كان هناك اجتماعات سلسله
اجتماعات اخر هذه الاجتماعات اول امس في
الكنيست عمليا جمعا نتنياهو مع وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي وقاده الجيش والمساد
والمخابرات كذلك الامر للبحث في التطور
الدراماتيكي الحاصل حقيقه بالنسبه
لاسرائيل وهو ان ايران وصلت الى 84%
تخصيبا لليورانيوم اي تفصيلها 6% فقط
للوصول الى 90% المطلوبه للانتاج العسكري
تستطيع ان تفعل ذلك في خلال يومين ان
ارادت ايران وهذا الامر تدركه اسرائيل
تماما لكن وفق العارفين في الشان
الاسرائيلي هناك عده اوجه لهذا التسريب في
هذا التوقيت الاول باليمين نتنياهو الان
في خضم الازمه الداخليه يريد ان يحدث
تناوين في اتجاهات اخرى في الخطر الخارجي
الذي يعيق مواجهته
الاحتدام وسجال الداخلي هذا من جهه من جهه
اخرى الشعور في اسرائيل بان اسرائيل شبه
وحيده في هذا الموضوع بمعنى وهذا يتصل
ربما بالمناورات العسكريه على ضرب المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه التي ارادت لها اسرائيل
ان تكون ضجيجا اعلاميا علنيا في اكثر من
مناسبه لتبرير رساله لايران كي لا تقفز
الى التسعين في المئه علما بان اسرائيل
كانت حددت كما هو معروف لمن يتذكر قبل عشر
سنوات 20% خطا احمر لمهاجمه ايران بعد ذلك
60% الان فوق ال 80% وصولا الى 90%
وبالتالي هناك ضغط كبير في اسرائيل في هذا
الاتجاه علما بان القدرات العسكريه حاليا
غير جاهزه لشن هجوم يعني افهم بذلك ان
ايران بحسب الحسابات الاسرائيليه قد
تجاوزت الخطوط الحمر حاليا
هذا صحيح بالنسبه للاسرائيليين هي تقترب
من الخط الاحمر الجديد وهو 90% انت تذكر
بنيامين نتنياهو يحمل صوره رسمه لقنبله
نوويه في
الامم المتحده واشير الى 90% هذه المرحله
الاخيره هذا خط احمر رسمه حينها ايران
قريبه جدا التقديرات في اسرائيل بان ايران
لم تتخذ قرارا بالانطلاق الى هذا الموضوع
بعد هناك رغبه باسرائيل والوكاله الذريه
للطاقه الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
بفحص ما اذا كان هذا فعلا عن طريق الخطا
وهذا قد يحدث في التقسيط عالي المستوى ام
ان ايران ارادت عمليا ان تستفز العالم في
هذا
الاتجاه لكن بدون ان شك بان التسريب اجتاز
الرقابه العسكريه اولا سمح به والهدف منه
هو رساله اساسا لايران لردعها عن القفز
الى 90% نعم
العربيه زياد حلبي مشاهدينا ننتقل الان
مباشره لمتابعه هذا المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير
الخارجيه الروسيه ورئيس لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه الصينيه
لتطوير العلاقات الصينيه الروسيه وانا
اقيم
[موسيقى]
الصداقه التي بنيت لعده من عده سنوات بين
بلدين ونحن سوف نستمر بتواصلنا القريب
والوثيقه
بفضل التوجهات الاستراتيجيه للرئيس
شينجين بينجو والرئيس بوتين فنحن نقوم
بتطوير العلاقات الشراكه والاستراتيجيه
والرغم في رغم التقلبات في الوضع الدولي
فان روسيا والصين يحافظون دائما على
حسب الاستراتيجي ويسعون بشكل قوي لتشكيل
عالم متعدد
الخطاب ونحن دائما ندعم ما هذا
العنوان اتعدد الاخطاب ونحن دائما
نقف مع بناء طريق
لتطور على اساس الاعتماد
على الوضع القومي والوطني وايضا نحن دائما
نفتح المجال للتطوير في
التعاون على خطوات متعدده بين روسيا
والصين مهما تغير الوضع في الساحه الدوليه
فان الصين ستبقى متمسكه وحريصه مع روسيا
لبذل الجهود في الحفاظ على
الايجابي بين الدول العظمى
سنه تعتبر السنه الاولى
للعمل على
تنفيذ انجازات
المؤتمر العشرين في الصين
ونحن سوف نستمر
بالسياسه القريبه
لبناء العلاقات ذات المنفعه المتبادله
ونحن سوف نستمر
بتطوير
بلادنا
وتطور الصين سوف
يكون
طاقه اضافيه للعالم اجمع ونحن عبر تطورنا
تطوير الصناعات الصينيه سوف نفتح افاق
كبيره
لتطوير التعاون ليس فقط مع روسيا ومع
الدول الاخرى في العالم وانا مستعد معكم
صديقي ان اجري
لقاء والحوار حول المصالح المشتركه
شكرا على اهتمامكم
مشاهدينا نكون معكم اذا في متابعه لهذا
المؤتمر الصحفي بين وزير الخارجيه الروسي
كبيره دبلوماسيين الصينيين والذي قال من
خلاله
كبيره الدبلوماسيين الصينيين ننام منفتحون
على زياده التعاون مع روسيا وايضا ندعم
نظاما عالميا متعدد الاقطاب وسنستمر في
تواصلنا الوثيق مع روسيا وسنوافيكم لمزيد
من التفاصيل حاله وروتها حول هذا الملف
بالعوده الى سياق نشاطنا وفي محافظه ديالى
العراقيه تضاربت الروايات الرسميه بشان
المجزره التي وقعت يوم الاثنين الماضي
واودت بحياتي تسعه مزارعين ضمنهم امراتان
في منطقه جياليه شمال شرقي بعقوبه مركز
المحافظه فمن جانب اتهم النائب عن
المحافظه رعد الدهلكي ميليشاتا ميليشيات
المسلحه منفلته بالتورط في المجزره ومن
جهه اخرى قالت خليه الاعلام الامني ان
نزاع عشائريا بين قريه الجيال الجيايلا
واليوبالي بل البوبابلي في قضاء الخالص في
محافظه ديالى ادى الى قتل وجرح عدد من
المواطنين مؤكده القاء القبض على عدد من
المتورطين في الحادث لاتخاذ الاجراءات
القانونيه بحقهم وتجري حاليا عمليه متابعه
وملاحقه متورطين الاخرين في الحادث
[موسيقى]
ة ما عندنا رحمه الله الله
نشاطنا مستمر مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
الرئيس قيس سعيد يصف الهجره لتونس
بالمؤامره
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد على ضروره اتخاذ اجراءات عاجله
لوقف تدفق المهاجرين غير النظاميين من
افريقيا الى بلاده واصفا ظاهره بانها
مؤامره لتغيير التركيبه الديموغرافيه في
تونس واكد السعيد خلال تراس اجتماع لمجلس
الامن القومي انا ظاهره توافد المهاجرين
غير النظاميين تؤدي الى عنف وجرائم
وممارسات غير مقبوله يجب وضع حد لها
قرر قاضي التحقيق في القسم القضائي
لمكافحه الارهاب مواصله التحقيق مع رئيس
حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي حيث سيمثل مجددا
غدا امام القضاء بتهمه استخدام كلمه
الطاغوت ولقاء عناصر من تنظيم انصار
الشريعه الارهابيه
مره اخرى يمثل امام قطب القضاء لمكافحه
الارهاب راشد الغنوشي رئيس حركه النهضه
بتهمه جديده تتمثل في استعماله كلمه تاغوت
وهي العباره ذاتها التي كان يستعملها
تنظيم انصار الشريعه الارهابي المحظور في
تونس عندما كان يؤذن احد انصار النهضه
التصريح واضح لكن الغنوشي يسر على ركوب
صهوه الهروب الى الامام
عرب
ويتم بملفات فارغه لا تثمن ولا تغني من
جوع
الغنوشي متهم ايضا بلقاء عناصر من تنظيم
انصار الشريعه الارهابيه اما المخطط قد
يكشف عنه البحث عن لمثوله الخميس المقبل
امام قطب مكافحه الارهاب القضايا المرفوعه
ضد الغنوشي وغيره اعتبر التعافي للسلطه
القضائيه تعافي القضاء سيفتح بابا لكل
لبحث كل القضايا العالقه وهذا سيحتاج الى
الكثير من الوقت لان القضايا الارهابيه
ليست قضيه سرقه موصوفه يمكن ان يتم
اثباتها على سارق وبالتالي تحتاج الى وقت
وتشهد تونس موجه ايقافات لعدد من
المتورطين في قضايا فساد وتامر على امن
الدوله تنظر فيها الدوائر القضائيه
المختصه
المؤسسه القضائيه وتخلصها من سيطره
الاخوان تعددت التهم والمواجهه لراشد
الغنوشي بين قضايا الارهاب وتبييض الاموال
والفساد في انتظار استكمال تحقيق معه
بوصفه المسؤول الاول عن العشريه السوداء
ومهندسه ما رفقها من احداث وليد عبد الله
العربيه
تونس
مشاهدينا ننتقل الان الى متابعه هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي المباشر من بغداد لوزير
الخارجيه الايراني حسين الامير عبداللهيان
رقتها وزير الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين
بشكل
مشتركو اهميته
فمستقلها
عراق
تصميمه من اقلام
سياسي
مرحله دولت ماردون
نقطه قوه بالنسبه للعراق
قوه العراق وامنه وتقدمه
نعتبرها من
قوتنا وتقدمنا وامننا
الايرانيه خلال المباحثات الصناعيه على ان
المشتركات بين الشعبين
عديده بحيث انه يمكن القول انه في ظل
العلاقات الاستراتيجيه والمتميزه القائمه
بين ايران والعراق
في الحقيقه نحن شعب واحد في جغرافيتين
مستقلتين
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا كنا معكم في متابعه لهذا المؤتمر
الصحفي من بغداد لوزير الخارجيه العراقي
فؤاد حسين و نظيره الايراني حسين امير
عبداللهيان وقد قال وزير الخارجي العراقي
نتمنى عوده واشنطن الى مباحثات فيينا
وتطرقنا مع وزير خارجيه ايران الى مستحقات
ايران لدى العراق وربط السكك الحديديه
والمزيد من التفاصيل التي يمكن ان نناقشها
ونتابعها في سياق النشرات المقبله
وبالعوده الى سياق نشاطنا ولمنع التوترات
المحتمله طلب الحرس الثوري الايراني من
حكومه ابراهيم رئيس عدم الاعلان عن
ميزانيه عدد من المؤسسات منها شرطه
الاخلاق وذلك بحسب وثائق سريه تضم تقارير
صادره عن منظمه استخبارات الحرس الثوري
حول الوضع الاقتصادي في البلاد تعود الى
شهر ديسمبر الماضي حيث كشف موقع ايراني
ترناشونال ان اجهزه استخبارات الحرس
الثوري طرحت في التقرير مطالبه الى
الحكومه الايرانيه لمواجهه ما سمي
باستعداد العدو واجندته لشن الحرب النفسيه
مع التاكيد على ضروره ادراجها تحت عنوان
نفقات اخرى
عبر رئيس مجلس القياده اليمني رشاد
العليمي عن شكله للسعوديه بعد ايداعها
مليار دولار في حساب البنك المركزي اليمني
وقال ان السعوديه صاحبه رؤيه مسؤوله تجاه
اليمن ولطالما استاندت اقتصاد بلاده وخففت
من معاناه شعبه ونشير الى هذا الخبر
العاجل مجلس الدوما الروسيه بنى تعليق
مشاركه روسيا في معاهده ستارت بالعوده الى
سياق نشاتنا مره اخرى مشاهدينا اشاهدا
رئيس الوزراء اليمني معين عبد الملك
بنوديعه السعوديه مؤكدا انها ستدعم جميع
مؤسسات الدوله اليمنيه واضاف عبد الملك في
تصريحات للعربيه انا الوديعه السعوديه
ستسلم في تحقيق الاستقرار النقدي وستدعم
قدرات البنك المركزي اليمني للوفاء
بالتزاماته واشار ايضا الى ان اليمن يواجه
تحديات كبيره في ظل التهديدات الارهابيه
للميليشيات
بقي ان نذكر مشاهدينا بابرز العناوين
الخلافات بين زعيم قوه فاغنر ووزير الدفاع
الروسي تظهر للعلن وبوتين يتعهد بملاحقه
الخونه
هزات انفداديه جديده تضرب مدينه القهرمان
مرعش التركيه
وزلازل اخرى تطال ايران وفلسطين
نتنياهو يتحدث عن رفع مستوى الجهوزيه لشن
هجوم ضد منشات النوويه ايرانيه بعد خمسه
اجتماعات سريه
شرطه الاخلاق الايرانيه تعود الى الواجهه
مجددا والحرس الثوري يطالب باخفاء
ميزانيتها
نهايه نفس المشاهدينا كونوا بعافيه
[موسيقى]